I smile because I know how this ends up
and I win and you
[Music]
this was last Monday morning in your
life start with this little shadows he
made on that jet engine mixed game of
Nate
it is Saturday night 6:36
hot date with Nate makes a real Suns fan
so that's funny
31 Arizona got our tickets excited Nate
get his Thunder here all right what do
we got today could be a short episode we
can throw these over we doing this sushi
thing we will have some filming do we
have Trouty setting it up proper said
we'll have a continuation of some
filling for G rapid is good so maybe we
get some more content but I'll go on
Facebook Instagram live in a second
actually local Facebook what and what's
on my mind reading some comments today
here and there Sam will [ __ ] beams
you know like to grade three same old
beams another
good I know what I wanted to do in this
episode I wanted to get you
[ __ ] to subscribe I realize I
don't do really hardcore right hooks to
subscribe I also you know how we used to
do the flash up of like follow Gary on
Instagram and we want to do a little bit
more nap but also subscribe the little
red one for to subscribe we really don't
like I want to do it miss stuff like the
amount of people who are watching and
like every day and discovering and
they're not subscribing which then
doesn't remind them I mean Dirac mmm the
rest of the Galant want to talk about me
I'm on the same concept comment muscles
so you know some people get beer muscles
like they get you know AB you know times
alright make a little liquor in them and
they think they can fight comments
muscles I'm so I went back exactly like
my sports muscles such as a Garre so I
have sports muscles I go to a Jets game
all of a sudden I got to beat out people
and I want to start fights and it's
crazy but I'm noticing a lot of people
have have a have comment muscles I got
into this rabbit hole and slide back
from London where I went back like 240
30 episodes you know ago and then all
the way back to like episode 1215 1927
he call if he did a little crispy man
who kind of went like the guy or gal
that rose up cooking with her
grandmother in the kitchen is always
going to beat the person that goes to
culinary school you know it's kind of
the essence of doing it he said that
that quote inspired his friend and
changed that person's life and is now at
ironically one of the great culinary
schools and has a profession it's kind
of funny but you know it's just crazy I
mean I wish it on all of you I wish it
on all of you to know that even though
you're going after your own
self-interest by proxy by sawdust by
process you're bringing so much good to
the world
it's an incredibly intoxicating feeling
I get equal if not slightly more value
out of putting in the actual work that
has allowed me the attempt for the
audacious goals that I'm crying for
myself as soon as I start seeing kids
who never had an entrepreneurial bone in
their body who never sold a thing in
their life who never cared about any of
that stuff and come we're coming out of
college and starting business
that's when I was like 24 months ago
that's when I was like oh this is
starting to get a little awkward I would
like to just read the very last
paragraph of your book I'm sorry I'm
hearing a lot of commercial positive
okay all daddies
we've been getting some snaps and they
can feel it going to be a little bit
more London I'm humbled I love you love
Creek and clarity about tonight yes the
park is going to be closed Lord is going
to be outside for the quarter like
that's how I'm rolling we do rock you
didn't need to look at what I just saw
[ __ ] Jesus Christ
all right that's going to end up a
little bit bigger than we thought
[ __ ] me thanks for being here okay you
are calm easy rock
[Applause]
all right I started seeing way too much
chatter of like people not being able to
make it of it maybe we'll meet like 20
or 30 people in the corner and I
misjudged it a little bit anyway and the
amount of you [ __ ] that have
comment muscles things like Garrity
watch out I'm coming after you and then
I click and one year later you ain't
coming up there [ __ ] you're in the same
exact spot talking about the same about
things making the same damn excuses
doing nothing so comment muscles I want
to create a culture of eliminating a lot
of you from comment muscles and getting
into action you know everybody's a tough
guy with an anonymous [ __ ] name and
their two cents in a comment on YouTube
and on Instagram and those places it's a
whole different thing to do something
about it and so while you're critiquing
everybody's actions on the web and
adding your cue sense people going out
and making me sense you understand so
all you comment heroes all you people
with comment muscles wake the [ __ ] up
nobody gives a [ __ ] 99% of people think
you're trolls and really delete you I
just let you stay in my comments and I
smile I smile because I know how this
ends up and I win and you lose
[Music]
really I just end it with you know let's
go matic little and I know how it ends
up and we cut into some [ __ ] music
intimacy
not this nice this said I'm going to
tell you what happens what happens if
you keep commenting and nothing [ __ ]
happens and I continue to do and execute
and you're going to cry and then 20
[ __ ] 29 you're going to leave a
comment under whatever I'm do do calm
and you look you know what [ __ ] it I got
a really handed to Gary Vee he did do it
you're exactly right [ __ ] I did
do it because I've already done it and
I'm gonna continue to do it and you're
gonna leave your snarky ass comment with
no [ __ ] icons I just feel bad I want
you to do better than that cuz I'm gonna
get mine you're not bothering me for
[ __ ] I like it keep leaving them fires
me to [ __ ] up
love it you know me mate this is how I
play basketball I like it it's the only
snake tell them the only time I don't
know if you even know the simmer because
you really kind of retired from
basketball but like I'm not going to
feed you I feel like there's no way for
me to ask it without beating you it I
think I genuinely hit more baskets when
somebody's hands in my face and I think
people leave me wide open like I do just
like I'd say I'm driven by it it's why I
think I really really didn't you mad
yeah that was a bad moment
why'd you have to bring that up I was on
a roll you like just killed my vibe
you killed my vibe do you remember I'm a
DJ wasn't me oh yeah days ago age' was
the most upset I don't know what
happened
you're fine what do you mean don't yoyo
yeah but what happened was you know like
I was I was a little bit harder and
needed to be it was here's the bottom
line like this back and forth you're a
classic 2010 basketball player I come
from the 90s when like those kind of
hits from I'm you know what I'm talking
about those 90 Knicks teams yeah that
was fine I felt it was super appropriate
I wasn't that upset I you know what to
your credit I don't want to put you on
blast you're right everybody else is
more upset because you're a competitor
your competitor - I was a hell medium
post about him link that [ __ ] up Nate's
[ __ ] here Nate sitting in this car
right now because he's good at
volleyball antenna never lost to me in
tennis yeah that hurts right you wish
you won that five who's the best one yet
five - five - right
yeah that hurt so what we're gonna say
oh so so the reason I think I'm very
built for this is good segue so many
people like how do you deal with the
haters so many people aren't putting out
content so many of you are not doing
things right now because you're worried
about people's feedback and it drains
you and it kills you and somebody's
saying you suck you're ugly you're fat
you're not smart shut the [ __ ] up nobody
cares you were privileged you had it
easy it cripples you not me I just don't
know how to tell you not me it feeds me
I love the love you guys know even last
episode of this at compliments I feed
off compliments and I feed off heat now
stop me
sit up histograms what up what up what
up max is it ready Tyler people are
waiting for dailyvee we got a place for
quiche 0% complaining yes so he could
see the banner people here plate wants
to have this case you guys friends or
you guys have a weird rivalry rivalry
forget it look at her rivalry bureau
rivalries yeah I mean here's my take on
that people if you're a rivalry he's not
doing it right
such a life it'll appear I believe me
right who's your biggest rival reflexes
rowdy people of the day really like this
ok ok and now you guys are friends
because this I think always there
watching you just assume everybody's
watching out I appreciate the ha my
rival Gary will then Jesse to your deep
[ __ ] thank you see you later girls yes
I'm gonna join up you'll join us yeah ok
cuz you know Xerox joining us and I
guess oh come on the phone number to
them giving you one of my heart and we
ended up at any time so look about in
the record repugnant punish that push
agendas a bad judgment icon for this
consequence wanted I'm being honest
these moments never let I said in
watching Pat but so far now for the
crash wasn't miss Amanda is my number
tactic is now but a major factor
releasing yes but nothing this because
my daddy practice senator Ronald from
front to back that I know with all its
every addict tips every continent it's a
very similar they're very mountainous
fortified for the soul but it's all
supposedly a fragile my make someone
gear up bigger bigger Nick's loss
yeah shut up for the lottery
10:11 next loss if you touch it's called
the transition cut my feminine work day
whole as I've seen them struggling
survivors where I learned in the
sacrifices enough someone so much that
you put your dream gonna jump to provide
a life with them that you've never
having yourself over : imagine people
are documents over no football season
summer stresses but never sent over
messages rather see the progression is
they'll be back in this thing that is
mind-boggling self assistance over three
other six they can pick something your
problems and situations in this if
there's a single money that's been the
sole their mothers it if there's no
global conference what you've amassed an
amount of wealth and investing the
crucifix in the temple saving yourself I
excel you would [ __ ] hopeless
possession be pessimistic the poster
child for the same negativity I will
never be no robbery my lost in my
thoughts I'm doing the best I can I have
to pull up something nation is a
critical